Wehling on what you stopped on is the
quickest way for the next thing not to
work all great stuff especially when
you're innovating doesn't happen right
away number one mistake so many people
make is they care about what other
people have what anybody has if I have
more if I left as a matter I worry about
myself he's an American entrepreneur
investor and four times New York Times
bestselling author he's best known as a
digital marketer and social media
pioneer he's an angel investor or
adviser to uber Birchbox
twitter facebook snapchat and tumblr
he's Gary Vaynerchuk and here's my take
on his top ten rules for success volume
two
rule number three is my personal
favorite and I'd love to know which one
you guys like the best and as always
guys if you hear something that really
resonates with you please leave it down
the comments below
put quotes around it as well so other
people can be inspired also when you
write it down you're much more likely to
lock it in for yourself as well
enjoy
what if I told you this was the last
Monday morning of your life
what if I told you you died this week
would you complain about your crap job
or that test you don't want to take I
doubt it you go much higher level
thinking well that's really what it
takes it takes understanding that if
you're not pumped right now if you're
grunting what you're about to do if
you're if you're not looking forward to
it look I respect practicality you got
to go through school because your
parents want to you got to pay your rent
you got student loans I get it but
please recognize the world we're living
in we're living in a world where is so
much more opportunity this internet
thing created way more opportunity for
all of us way more I mean you only not
even be alive but your mom and dad could
have had sex like three minutes later
and you weren't even exist and you're
complaining you could have ended up
being a buck a tree I just don't get the
mentality of being head down sad on a
Monday morning I'm going to make Monday
morning like I'm going to make things
Saturday Monday morning that's what I
want to do every morning and that's what
I want from you please take a step back
and think about how awesome it actually
is and then recognize that you can
attack the world in a totally different
way because you are lucky enough to be
born during this era so many people come
up to me and say Gary it's so hard I
look at their Instagram and they're not
posting any of their content with
hashtags
which is a by accident way to pick up
exposure in a world where they have no
money when you have no money when I took
over my dad's business it did three
million dollars a year ten percent gross
profit three hundred thousand dollars
before expenses my first year marketing
budget was fourteen thousand dollars
when you have no money and I built that
business from a three to a sixty million
dollar business in five years I had to
make every penny perfect so I was right
about email marketing in ninety six and
I was right and because of that I had
ninety one percent open rates when
Google AdWords came out the day it came
out I paid five cents a click for words
before anybody bid me up and I was super
right and that worked it was is that
luck versus preparation and you ever get
anything wrong what do you do I can make
them inviting I give everything wrong
it's just that I can't recall it because
once it's wrong I'm moving on to the
next thing like
- well dwelling on what you stop on is
the quickest way for the next thing not
to work right yeah so like so I think I
do everything I mean you know this this
is a fun thing to say some people in the
back notice I was a breakout YouTube
star in the first year 2006 I decided
that the right strategy was to leave
YouTube completely and go to viddler
because viddler offered me equity in
their company and I've left an enormous
amount of attention I deviated from my
intention thesis to do short-term
economics and equity in a company and I
lost I lost Wendy right finally came in
my life two years ago we started to try
to build up my youtube for the first
time I was sitting on 40,000 user
followers in a world where I could have
had millions if I just stayed the course
so I make mistakes all the time
I'm reorganize its based on a mistake I
made the prior year I just don't give up
about my mistakes everybody else cares
about your mistakes if you're worried
about your own mistakes you've already
lost sometimes a lot of people may try a
new initiative and then they don't get
an immediate reaction me and they think
it's a failure right I want to add to
your YouTube videos with the Wine
Library you know you had so much content
out there how did you stick in there how
did you keep yourself motivated because
I believe in my strategy and I'm patient
ish like all great stuff especially when
you're innovating doesn't happen right
away this notion that like Oh Gary I
tried it I spent 500 bucks on Facebook
Ads it doesn't work well with your video
sucked what if your product and service
sucks I I tend to do things that are
very early that has been my career easy
I when I do things I believe in them I
stick with them based on intuition even
though for 18 months nobody watched my
wine videos at all I knew it was right I
was right there's been things I've done
that I jumped off of very quickly I
started - Gary B app-v chat ve like we
Chad's I was funny for my fans great CRM
one on one didn't feel right after week
or twos complaining money building it
knew it stopped it after you know a
couple months up Wine Library TV five
years every day YouTube decided to
change it to daily grape insular app you
could buy stuff subscription for reviews
it was a lot of fun only identified
stopped it because if you feel led
anymore it's always hard to know when to
jump off something new but I find that
people don't believe in what they're
doing they hear a guru and they do it
begrudgingly because their boss wants
them to or they're like well Gary's
right a lot so let me do it but they
don't believe it and so then they jump
they're looking for nose instead of yes
is everything I do every business
development every event I do every time
I try new marketing tactics or sales
tactic I'm looking for the yes right I'm
looking for the yes and if the no
punches me will then I'm like crap then
no punched me I believe the majority of
people when they try new tactics are
looking for the no and you're going to
getting a lot of subtle knows
immediately right and so I think that's
why that happens you didn't take care
about everything and it starts with
yourself look yourself in the mirror and
ask yourself what do I want to do every
day for the rest of my life do that I
promise you can monetize that if you
love out through an Alf blog you collect
Smurfs Smurfs it up whatever you need to
do do it so many people are talking
about I can't monetize I can't monetize
there's a billion seven-year-old
douchebags that are in control right now
but the number two percent at 34 year
old lady she's going to buy you're she's
going to put the advertising on your
stuff it's coming stop crying and just
keep hustling I'm desperate for people
to start defining their hopes and dreams
and wants and needs on their terms not
on what I say I don't care if you want
to hustle 18 hours a day I really don't
I really really don't I don't care you
want to
I don't care what you want or need you
need to care about what you wanted
you can't worry about what I'm saying
you can't worry about for your flavor of
the month is right maybe I'll just wave
of the month like maybe maybe maybe
you're consistently burn of the life is
your mom's going of you is your older
brother who's quite a difference in
wisdom which wants you to be a lawyer
but you don't want to be a ward of the
artist you want to you want to take a
chance to be an entrepreneur or the
reverse or the reverse I know many
teachers and loves entrepreneurship more
than me but I think you see all the time
talking about like self-awareness heart
you want this is the golden era for
entrepreneurship people ask them for
selfies this will go away it may not
always win but it's going to go away but
you know it's entrepreneurship like a
rap artist like a baseball player like
the heavyweight nobody cares who the
heavyweight champion of the world is
right now goto cares who's the best but
they surely did in 1969 and 1954 for a
heavyweight champ or you know they
change they change and it will always
change and it will continuously change
and right now our supreme worships in
this pedestal is having its moment and
when I'm fearful of is that you watch my
videos my Instagram quotes and what I
want to clarify for everybody is I hope
you understand I am NOT giving advice to
everybody the only place I'd like to
give everybody is to do you define what
your North Star is to understand
yourself to understand what your work
like balance
ambitions are how much what your
financial ambitions are we
like challenges are the problems that
you want to try to solve in sure as we
all do as humans try to climb those
different mountains in our lives what
makes you tick that is all that matters
don't do if you know I don't think they
leave you for all these videos for you
to be like me I don't think anybody
should be like me boy learn our enormous
amounts of pressures and sacrifices that
I recognize you're just not healthy or
valuable to anybody else but it's also
not healthy or valuable to me to do some
of the things that you want me to do
like it's not fun for me to work 9:00 to
5:00 like I will break I will be is
equally devastated as you would be to
work till midnight every day and so we
just need a call to action for everybody
recognize we have to stop judging
everything I'm not judging you I'm
creating content for you to use as a
barometer to try to figure out what you
like and what you don't like and I'm
trying to provide values in my words my
actions and my content to bring the
people to ever buy their world and
that's really that's the clarification
like I don't want people to to be like
me I don't want people to think a lot
people to do themselves and they just
have to start understanding themselves
and not trying to be like me of this
moment or that person in Mexico miss
that person next moment the people that
most really choose themselves and
figuring themselves
the problem is if using the greatest
hammer and the greatest screwdriver and
the greatest wrench the greatest in
front of you if you don't use them
properly you will lose right if there's
a nail that I have to put in that ground
but I take the wrench and I hit it when
the hammer was right there it still
comes down to the practitioner and you
have to be good at your craft and you
have to love you if you love sales if
you don't love it you have no chance
because it's so hard it's so painful
there's so much rejection right so those
are the things I think about
so technology's CLE enablers you just
said there that it that the person is
equally important and we're important
right and go right for you but I just
apologize for jumping in but let me make
it perfectly straight if I go play Roger
Federer
right now in tennis and I'm the greatest
tennis racket ever made
like from taken from the Mars as new
like resources great and he took a John
McEnroe 1974 tennis racket he would whip
my ass like I'm crushing sales people
that have every sales force every one of
your competitors 37 features upgraded
went to every Pro Conference watching
this I will beat their ass in sales
every day of the week right your talent
and your apology other a a precision air
has truly really put me over my five
bucks by the way by the way that's the
same answer for everybody in this room
that's what humans are good at we all
fail we've all failed like there by I my
parents haven't been killed my child and
there's people that have their children
died but could you imagine like the
idealisms like listen unfortunately or
fortunately depends on how one wants to
look at it I'm a pretty optimistic guy I
lost three of my four grandparents
before I was really before I knew them
before I was born in one very early on
like so you know it's nothing for me to
be happy I want in the right order the
health and well-being of my family and
there's nothing even remotely close to
that not even with not even remotely
people have gotten three much worse
this is lie in front of we call our
grandparents and our great-grandparents
people were persecuted and kill like I
just we not have real headaches you know
I don't know why I have this highly
emotional and then completely
unemotional part of me but I mix them
together to create the balance and
that's what works for me so of course
there's nothing that I couldn't get
upfront like every other human ever
besides somebody who now lives in some
weird cave that we don't know about you
know I mean we are sluggish
we're really strong we're just being
sold that we're not because there's a
lot of money a lot of money and telling
us that we're not pretty enough thin
enough smart enough good enough that I
want to tell you your best conditions
I've been feeling a little bit
unmotivated and I've been feeling like I
should be doing something or I should be
just I feel like I should be pulled and
like it isn't I'm feeling uninspired
basic that's my question how do you get
when you lose inspiration and you lose
motivation how do you get it back I'd
get it back by remembering that I might
die tomorrow that's true
so I'm inspired by practicality and
reality and the truth which is it is
ridiculously impossible to become a
human being I am one I have other good
things going for me as a human being and
I'm just grateful you your dwelling and
looking at what you don't have versus
looking at what you have if you actually
looked at what you had your health you
know living in America you know who the
heck knows what would be on your list if
you actually spent all your time looking
at that versus I don't have a million
dollars I'm not famous I don't have this
if you spent all your time on what you
have versus what you don't have you will
be the happiest girl on earth filled I
love my business go inside I'll take it
up here I'm trying to launch it so for
which one is business I don't know you
well enough you know
you know what I mean they both work
which one do you want to do I would like
to try to thicken up - you prefer Gabi
okay well that's why you're asking which
one will you do
I wouldn't take either what could you do
them I can't answer that for you fear is
holding you back you know what you want
to do well the only reason you're not
doing is because they're scared of doing
what you actually want to do right are
you scared to do it cuz your parents
won't like it
no my father studies to look to me okay
so when you scared of failing not
failing that still being at the same
place when my friends are the next level
huge mistake
you know what the same thing your
friends want so I hear what they have
number one mistake so many people make
is they care about what other people
have don't give anybody has if I have
more if I left doesn't matter I worry
about myself the fact that you're
worrying about other people's
accomplishments is already a losing
formula you need to get rid of that
first then you can focus on yourself
thank you you understand you know to be
great I could get the fight
and I very much think that my success is
a product of some level of skill but I
do think I win because I outwork people
I really do believe that I do believe
that 100% and I'm not sure that if my
dad didn't set that example that I'd
even have the ability to think one could
work that hard the fact that I've been
working 19 hours a day every day for the
last 20 years is easy for me is the only
clear idea right I was poor I sucked at
school it was your own gear I have you
know I think you need to recognize that
on that your biggest advantage is that
you're hungrier than your competitor and
that if you are not applying your one
advantage which is your work ethic and
the powers that you have to put into
your business well then you're going to
come up short I sit here with enormous
assumptions around all of you that
you're just too soft
right that I think that you've had a
better and that that alone doesn't
allows somebody will come lift with the
counter of cultural point of view and
they like Gary that's cool but I don't
have to work that hard because I'm
working smarter yeah me too I work hard
and smart
now why but there's a 12 hour 10 hour 8
hour 15 hour work that you can finish a
lot of things in those 18 12 9 hours or
you can finish the medium amount of
things or like we think people focus on
too many small details way too many
people just remember going for the next
30 40 years of their lives trying to
check the boxes other things that
they're not as good at and that you're
going to wasted a lot of time in B's I
highly recommend for all you have firs
done a lot of there's a lot of you that
are always talking about Gary I do work
hard and you do you work 16 hours some
people just don't have the attention
span or the capacity to remember or like
there's a lot of things I can't learn I
was very poor student because the
subject matter bored me and if I was
forced to become great at understanding
the great artists of the 20th century
I'm in big trouble and so I would tell
people to bet on their strengths you
need to bet on your Springs and don't
give a about where you suck at and to
put themselves in a position to win with
their strengths it is that is absolutely
the straightest line to success
greatness comes from adversity and
looking the challenge in the eye and
having the intestinal fortitude to kind
of step up and go after it
[Music]
thank you guys so much for watching I'd
love to know what did you think of this
video how do you like our vol 2 series
leave it down the comments below I'd
also love to know what did you learn
from Gary today what did he say that had
the biggest impact on you what lesson is
your favorite and you're going to apply
immediately to your life or business
somehow leave it down the comments below
I'm super curious to find out finally
one thing for quick shout it to Richard
Galvez Richard thank you so much for
picking up a copy of my book your one
word it really really really means a lot
to me and I hope you're enjoying the
view so thank you guys again for
watching I believe in you I hope you
continue to believe in yourself and
whatever your one word is much love I'll
see you soon
Amy asks a professor once said to me
it's better to be a big fish in a small
pond do you agree
Amy this said you know I'm going to be
very upfront on this question that's a
good way to bang out the show that
sounds like a loser professor to me
it's small-time thinking I don't
subscribe to it there's a lot of
practicality in it right there's it's a
lot easier to be the most successful
businessman in st. Louis Missouri than
it is to be in the world right so I
understand the thesis but honestly that
to me is very conservative not in my DNA
thinking that could be great advice for
a lot of people who are delirious and
things that are better than they are
though I love to drive through
self-esteem and optimism and I think
early in your life you should absolutely
shoot for the highest stars that you can
I think as life moves on and time moves
on you need to become more practical
you've got bills and kids and all those
kind of things
but to start off one's career in the
first 20 years call to your 40 to be in
that thinking I think that limits there
have been so many people who've hedged
and settled in their lives and honestly
I'm not the kind of character that's
going to play in that kind of sphere I'm
going in a different direction it's what
comes natural to me but it's also
because I think I could be the biggest
and the baddest in any game I play it's
just how I'm wired I think this comes
down to it's probably very good advice
to some and it's probably atrocious
advice to others and this is why I
continue say if I could inject anything
into anybody it would be self awareness
because it would help you answer this
question because for a lot of people
it's probably really solid advice from
me and for many of you watching this
it's crap advice Allan asked as we've
seen you hate wasting time but how do
you adjust on days nothing is going
right well there's no such thing luckily
not I mean there's no I mean I don't
remember a day where nothing went right
I mean first and foremost the way I
really deal with it if we want to get
zen about this and a lot of you know
this is as long as everybody's healthy
everything went right I always quantify
when business doesn't go well I default
quickly to a business it's all about
life you know like well my kids look how
you my kids are look how thank God my
parents are alive like I quickly switch
from I don't dwell you know I'm not good
at dwelling I love speed and I don't
like wasting time dwelling complaining
wishing hoping you know pondering how
you wish it was is the single biggest
waste of time in life and in business
like the bottom line is we all wish
thinks I wish I was six foot four the
single best looking guy in the world and
the quarterback of the New York Jets
Evans won 19 straight Super Bowls I wish
that I wish that I mean I just wish that
I wish that and and and in the same way
that that's funny is the same way to
wish that like that deal went through or
that employee took the job or that
person didn't quit or that concept
didn't work out I mean I've had multiple
divisions multiple strategies here at
wine at Wine Library at vaynermedia that
haven't worked in the last 12 months yet
we're dismantling it and so much like
anything else you just it's like the
next it's the next play using artistic
stuff like if you're doing a Broadway
play what are you going to mess up a
line and just stop and just cry on stage
you just got to go to the next line you
just got to keep moving forward and so
how do I handle it easily I'm champ on
this issue I'm a champion I am an
absolute champion on this issue meaning
like I'm prepared for the punches in the
face I expect things not to go well I
it's kind of the way I prep for Jets
game Saturday night nobody likes being
around me because I'm just devastated
it's all bad we're going to use is we're
going to have it or lose or you know
like I'm subconsciously like that but
unlike the Jets where I say that
outwardly these guys can tell you I'm
only on winning an offense at all times
Adam asks I feel like I've lost my
hustle help what do I do
Adam anybody who's losing their hustle
have a lot of variables and there's a
lot of variables in this episode the
variable episodes there's a lot of
context books about just direct answers
today we're still listen you might have
you might not be passionate about your
North Star anymore I I've been going
through something let me actually break
from shattering news here for the
time in my life I've been thinking about
your things like sabbaticals and
building a business school in Haiti for
five years and like like I love listen
I'm still all about buying the New York
Jets
and it's the process of that and the
game but it's amazing for me to be in
tune with myself the maturity like as
you get older like just dip like my kids
are six and three and they're
interesting like it's they're
interesting and like you start you know
I start projecting what do they look
like at 13 and 15 like you're really
cool to like I don't believe in the
school system as much as everybody like
do I just take them and go do something
rogue like just different things like
you just evolved and and you might have
just lost your North Star the thing that
you thought you were going for might not
be it's why it was always happy that I
didn't want a million bucks or they want
fame or I didn't want a car private
plane or these little things like it was
fun to be like I want to buy the Jets
and what that always meant to me is I
want the process of buying the Jets
which means I get the hustle forever
because that's my that's who I am
maybe you've lost who you are or what
you want or maybe you've accomplished
kind of or maybe you feel it's
achievable I would quickly crushed if I
thought what I wanted to achieve was
super achievable and even happen to mean
the lineman's it's happening at Vayner
like as veiners becoming a player in the
agency world and we're not like that now
when I go like I'm super gonna be like
oh like you know like like that's not as
fun for me I like being the underdog
I like the climb you know I like that so
maybe that's happened maybe you're just
tired I mean I think one of the things
that the New York Jets do for me that
nobody understands if those hours
actually you just caught something on
dailyvee right meet on Durand Jeff that
was the first time I talked business
Dorner just came in 15 years I looked at
my phone the wrong time there's a very
big thing and I only spend a second on
it like I am escaped and relaxed and by
the way they care about it like that's
how excited like those three four hours
of escapism maybe need some vacation
time maybe you need to look at the
people around you maybe you need a
change maybe you need to break up with
your boyfriend or girlfriend like
there's like there's a lot of intense of
different things that can be happening
or maybe you can take a step back and
really listen to this statement which is
you've lost your hustle because you
really are not in tune to why you're
doing it right you're just not in tune
to what you do
that that you're maturing and realizing
like a Ferrari or a fat watch or
courtside tickets or custom Mike's I
would just wanted to show them you know
is not what you're living for and so you
know it's funny tonight I'm going to the
charity water gala I never thought of
myself ten years ago somebody who'd be
so involved in non-profit sitting on the
board of pencils of promise donating I
was you know I was old school in 40 I'm
older like this is this new narrative of
much better people and that's what I
think you guys all are I think you're
much better generation I grew up
thinking I'll get rich and when I'm old
I'll be like giving out money and doing
that stuff so you just evolved right and
so maybe maybe you like me like I
haven't gone completely like I don't
have enough money like my kids can give
away all the money but I can't I don't
have that luxury yet but maybe you want
to do nonprofit maybe you want to build
schools for pencils of promise it will
take you and Laos like maybe you've lost
your purpose so take a good step back
shut down shut down for 24 48 72 hours
go away go away like this this is how I
want you to shut down go to Airbnb this
is a 2016 way to shut down go to Airbnb
find a very remote place you know cut
doctor though I'm taping so yeah I'm
just wrapping up the show sorry go to go
to Airbnb find a very remote place
that's you get to at a low cost like a
crappy cabin far away on a 4-hour drive
where you can like just drive because
you can or like somebody will drive you
that are like hitchhike I don't give a
crap lowest cost farthest away seclusion
and just be with yourself and start
talking yourself for real for like
really talk to yourself a real one of
the great things I do with myself is I
talk to myself for real you know really
nobody is a harsher critic and a bigger
fan of themselves than me
and that friction in both directions
matters